هو في الاساس مهندس مدني قرر منذ اربع
سنوات تصويره ونشر مقاطع ساخره عبر
حساباتي على مواقع التواصل اليوم اصبح احد
اشهر صناع المحتوى في مصر وليد مصطفى له
طريقه وبصمه خاصه في الكتابه والالقاء
يقدم عروض سند ابكوميدي وهو صاحب برنامج
فضفضه الذي يتناول فيه موضوعات اجتماعيه
بشكل ساخر وليد يغني ايضا وله تجارب مهمه
في الدبلجه والتعليق الصوتي وحاليا يملك
نحو مليون ونصف المليون متابعه برفيسبوك
انستغرام
مصدومه لدرجه ان هي مش مصدقه ان هي ثابت
هي قاعده على امل التليفون اللي هيرن انا
لو صاحبتها ظهرتها عشان تهاون عليها
هتلاقيها وطلع لها كل الهدايا اللي هو
جابها لها طب بص يا اسراء احمد جاب لي ايه
في اسراء طبعا تمثل ان هي بتعيط من باب
الاحساس يعني لا لا ده ما يستاهل دي حيوان
وخانق مع ان هو ممكن يكون ما خلاهاش 90%
ما اخليهاش بس هو في عرف كده من البنات
اللي هو طالما سابوا بعض عن عمل المعامله
الخيال تبص على البوكس اللي فيه الهدايا
احمد جابها لها تلاقيه كله على بعضه مش
عامل 49 جنيه تختار مواضيع اجتماعيه
وتحطها بقالب من السخريه قلب ساخر على
مواقع التواصل انت تختارها الموضوعات وعلى
اي اساسمها بتبقى حاجات حصلت لي في حياتي
وانا باعاني منها في حياتي لان انا الاخ
الصغير وعندي اخوات كبار وعندي اولاد
اخوات وخريج هندسه فاشتغلت يعني لان
الحياه جاءت علي شويه
فمعظمها الحاجات انا بابقى لمستها او حد
حكى لي عليها طيب وليد يعني كمان قرانا
المقدمه عنك وانت تغني ايضا غنى هوايه
والاحتراف
انا لسه صاحي ههه
له ماضي له الذكرى قلبك قسي ولا نسي اكيد
عينيهقيك فاكراك
وليد مرتبط بعنوان فضفضه شو اللي صار وقت
نفضفضله هالايام
كوستر بس
فوق بقى ما انا قاعد بقى في اول صف فشايف
الحقيقه شايف الزحليقه يعني شايفه انا
نازل فين برولار كوستر اللي انا وليد
موضوعنا قبل شويه كان على توظيف الذكاء
الاصطناعي ومستقبل السوشيال ميديا مع اذا
كان السماعه في 20 22 انا قبل ما ادخل على
حسابك على انستغرام هيك تخيلت وسالت نفسي
انه معقوله يكون وليد من الناس اللي نزلوا
صورهم باستخدام الاي اييه وكيف يرى ذكر
الصناعي فعلا اول ما فتحت لقيت صورك شايفه
كده كان الصوره الفضاء
الصناعي في السوشيال ميديا في الدنيا كلها
وراح يكون عندك
ههه
طيب مصطفى انت عندك مليون ونص مليون
متابعه على مواقع التواصل الله يزيدهم
العام القادم شو الطريقه الخاصه اللي
خلىتك تستقطب كل هذا الجمهور على مواقع
التواصل هذا الاهتمام والنجاح والله مش
عايز اكبر المواضيع بس هو احترام احترام
عقلي اللي بيتفرج ان احنا نحاول نقدم له
حاجه تحترم عقله ويحس بيها ان هي يعني
تلمسه في شكل في اخر من حياته يعني طب
عندك طريقه خاصه في الكتابه والالقاء شو
اللي يميزك يا مصطفى عن غيرك الموجودين
يعني في كثار على مواقع التواصل اليوم
اللي بده ينشهر
بعد توفيق ربنا طبعا وكل حاجه احنا بنحاول
بس نكتب حاجه ما تبقاش مصفه ويبقى في
الاخر كده في هدف صغير هدف في وسط
كوميدي او البلاك كوميدي اللي بنعمله
طيب وليد في من احد ابرز اشياء الذكاء
الاصطناعي راح يعملها بيت 20 انه يحد من
المتنمرين انت في ناس كثير تبعث لك مثلا
انه تضايق من المحتوى اللي بتعمله ما
بيعجبها ممكن تتنمر على شكلك
المفروض ان الواحد يبقى عنده ثقه في نفسه
كافيه ما يتاثرش باي حاجه سلبيه حواليا
قوي يعني طيب
كوميدي
والحاجات بتاعتي والطلبت مني كثير جدا
فدخلت الاكسبيريا انا احب دائما اجرب
الحاجات الجديده فجربنا والحمد لله طلعنا
يعني
انت عارفه ليه بتعاطف مع المهندسين
اكثر فئه استغلالها خمس سنين وما بنستغربش
لو لقينا مثلا حد واخدها على سته ولا سبع
سنين بتقعد تدرس فيهم حاجات متنوعه بقى من
الشرق للغرب وانت يعني طالب غلبان جاي من
ثانويه عامه واخد على عينك اصلا مش فاهم
حاجه فاكر بقى ان الحياه الجامعه ورده